older buildings have lost stories they
have a lot of history
who live there who make this building
these are stories that need to be told
by restoring a building we cannot bring
this story to life
this great big story was made possible
by raffles hotels and resorts
[Music]
my name is yokong schwa i'm associate
professor at singapore university of
technology and design
[Music]
i have been in architecture conservation
for almost 20 years i restored churches
temples and institutional buildings
a restoration world is actually very
exciting it's about conserving our own
identity and heritage
buildings are with us for hundreds of
years proper restoration and care will
help to preserve the buildings and live
a part of history for future generations
the first step of restoration is to
really understand the history of the
building
we go to archives we look at historical
drawings historical plans the microfilm
room
then we'll go on to site to understand a
little bit more about the current
condition just like a doctor
we study deterioration factors why it
require restoration and what requires
our immediate attention
once we have a fuller picture of the
history and existing condition of
building we can plan how we are going to
carry out the actual restoration
for example song monastery is a huge
buddhist monastery comprising of many
different buildings
the bell and drum tower is reconstructed
in 1960s in a style that's incompatible
with the general architecture of
stronghold monastery so we're trying to
bring back the historic look
the duration restoration really depends
on the scale of the restoration are we
restoring the building in entirety or
we're restoring the building in parts
for example the stained glass of saint
joe cathedral will take about one year
to finish
we took around five years to restore the
jackie chan donation
strongling monastery has been restoring
their buildings for close to 30 years
and we are still not finished
the years i've restored many buildings
and one of the highlights of my career
is to win a unesco award for wakai
chengdu restoration project the oldest
duchy temple in singapore
i like to work on building with
interesting history and story so it's
not about whether the building is
beautiful or ugly
a successful restoration needs to be
true to the intention of the original
builder
we think that development and
conservation are at each other if we
need to develop we need to demolish old
buildings but i don't believe this
necessarily true in a city state like
singapore we need historic buildings to
create diversity of our cityscape
i hope that when people look at historic
buildings they're able to uncover the
stories and understand its history and
identity
[Music]
you